thousands of people are reportedly stuck
in queues at uk airports because of a
nationwide problem with the i.t system
at border control some people have
complained on social media about massive
weights apparently four to five hours at
heathrow border force staff are having
to manually check arrivals
well heathrow airport have released this
statement we are aware of a systems
failure impacting the e-gates which are
staffed and operated by border force
this is this issue is impacting a number
of ports of entry and is not an isolated
issue at heathrow our teams are working
closely with border force to find a
solution as quickly as possible
and edinburgh airport tweeted this
border force colleagues are working to
rectify an i.t issue which is resulting
in delays for arriving passengers
passengers will still be able to pass
through the border but this will take a
little longer than usual while the issue
is resolved
the uk border force i t issue is
nationwide and ukbf teams are working to
resolve this
all available uk border force staff are
in the arrivals hall to carry out
necessary checks and allow passengers to
pass through the border as quickly as
possible